The online music world
is going crazy
because alt rock squint gods
Radiohead--
one of my and Scott Aukerman's
favorite bands, I might add.
Scott and I have been to
Radiohead concerts together.
-Yes, we've been to see them
together several times. -Yeah.
They might release an album,
Scott!
Everything went down,
and there's...
-I know. I almost called you!
-I almost...
I didn't know we were gonna talk
about it here on television.
-HARRIS: Yeah.
-Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, there's a lot of clues.
There's a lot of clues.
First up-- fans were mailed
postcards that read,
"Burn the witch," and then
Radiohead began deleting
their entire social media
presence, uh, doing this.
There it goes.
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Who knows?
Who knows?
Why are they vanishing?
Either...
Either there's a new
Radiohead album,
or Thom's just
in one of his moods.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
Or maybe LP nine
is finally on the way.
So, uh, comedians, since all
we can do is theorize right now,
what do you think is going on?
Rachael.
I think they're really upset
that Miley stopped
following them on Twitter.
Points. I think so. Yeah.
(applause and cheering)
Very upset.
-(bell dings)
-Scott.
I think
Radiohead is being erased
like in Back to the Future
because Thom Yorke couldn't
trick his parents into (bleep).
-HARDWICK: Yeah, points. Right.
-(laughter)
-Right. -HARRIS: Okay.
-(applause and cheering)
(British accent): If they don't
dance, they can't fall in love.
If they don't fall in love,
they can't kiss,
-and then I'm history.
-(laughter)
"Let's play a Radio song
at the prom."
-Everyone scatters.
-(laughter)
Hey, Thom Yorke,
you know that new sound
you've been looking for?
-Well, listen to this!
-(laughter)
♪ Karma police...
-They're really funny...
-(laughter)
HARRIS:
Keep going. Keep going.
"Karma Police" at the Under
the Sea dance, and... Oh!
Makes it a much different movie.
Weird Al.
They're forsaking the Internet
and releasing their next album
exclusively on handmade
musical dream catchers.
HARDWICK:
Yes. Points. Points.
-(applause and cheering)
-That could be very true.
(with English accent):
We're releasing our next album
on spider web.
A spider will come
and spin a web
in your home
and pluck the strings.
(laughter)
Uh, please release another
album, Radiohead, and then,
-I... I want to meet you.
-(laughter)